et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
adrien quatre ans bonjour bonjour coup
d'être avec nous nous avons mené la
france insoumises du nord on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
eric richard de la nouvelle république -
eric bonjour orione bons joueurs
derrière on commence bien sûr puisque
vous êtes élu du nord des hautes france
par cette déclaration de xavier bertrand
votre président de région qui s'est donc
déclaré officiellement candidat à la
présidentielle il est également candidat
à sa succession dans la région des
hautes france qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé de cette déclaration du candidat a
beaucoup de choses xavier bertrand comme
tout le monde le voit donc d'abord c'est
le timing qui surprend parce que bon il
avait dit qu'il conditionnait le fait
d'être candidat à la présidence de la
république par le sa réélection à la
région pour l'instant s'est pas fait
alors est-ce que c'est ce que nous avons
fait que le rassemblement que nous avons
construit à gauche autour de karima
delli tête de liste écologie soutenue
par la france soumise qui l'inquiète
peut-être en tout cas il a
vraisemblablement voulu accélérer
j'achevais juste avant d'arriver sur
votre plateau la lecture de de
l'interview de xavier bertrand au point
ce que je note surtout c'est la férocité
antisocial des propositions qu'ils
portent
il propose de faire travailler les
français plus longtemps de baisser la
dépense publique on se demande où il va
continuer à le faire quand on regarde ce
qui a été fait à la fois par monsieur
macro mais aussi dans les précédents
kinkéla une droite sociale et par la
droite sociale heureusement que
l'étiquette ses écrits parce que
franchement quand on lève détail les
propositions se rend pas totalement
content non je crois par ailleurs que la
république en marche qui s'agitait
beaucoup hier soir sur les réseaux
sociaux annonce sa candidature peut être
rassuré quand on regarde l'interview de
xavier bertrand au point on a le
sentiment qu à peu de choses près à
l'intention d'appliquer le programme qu
emmanuel macron applique et avec en plus
l'intention peut-être de faire aboutir
une réforme des retraites qui pour
l'instant a été mise de côté
donc je crois d'ailleurs ce sera sans
doute sa principale difficulté à xavier
bertrand c'est qu'on a l'impression que
ne peut faire du maquereau nisme à la
place d'emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron et depuis un certain
temps s'est positionné comme en quelque
sorte le chef de la droite donc y avoir
une sorte de concurrence entre les deux
mais moi ce qui m'a dit vas y ait un
parallèle d aller vers 3 dit qu'il faut
restaurer l'autorité mise beaucoup sur
la sécurité mise beaucoup sur le travail
mons est cette interview cette interview
est banalement de droite emmanuel macron
depuis un certain temps clairement et
said occuper cet espace donc donc voilà
après le fait qu'il annonce sa
candidature outre le timing est sans
doute les inquiétudes qu'il a par
rapport à la régionale mais juste le
thème seul à permettre aux hôtels va
permettre que la campagne présidentielle
en quelque sorte s'accélère parce que
c'est vrai que pour l'instant et compris
à cause de la crise sanitaire on a
l'impression que la situation est
congelé l'entrée en campagne de xavier
bertrand on peut aussi peut-être faire
bouger les lignes et nous permet enfin
d'avoir de la contradiction sur les
projets et les programmes proposés et
justin je vais donner la parole à eric
charmes un dernier mot ce que vous dites
puisque vous dites c'est peut-être parce
qu'on lui a fait peur avec notre
candidature de la gauche unie ça veut
dire que pour vous xavier bertrand qui
disait qu'il allait faire des régionales
un tremplin pour la présidentielle il ne
disait pas comme ça montreuil
conditionné sa candidature
ça veut dire que maintenant il est en
train de faire de sa candidature à la
présidentielle un élan pour sa campagne
régionale c'est sympa comme ça il ya
sans doute une explication rationnelle
au fait qu'ils changent complètement son
calendrier il avait dit j'attends d'être
réélu à la région pour me présenter à la
présidentielle et il finalement ils
inversent le calendrier
posez lui la question je pense
qu'effectivement ça tient au fait que la
configuration de ces régionales était
pas celle qu'il attendait mais est ce
que pour vous c'est un problème qui soit
à la fois candidat aux régionales et
candidat à la présidentielle ou pour
vous de ça ne change rien mais ça montre
juste une chose c'est que finalement
l'ambition qu'il a pour les hôtes france
aujourd'hui c'est rien d'autre que
simplement s'en servir comme vous l'avez
dit d'un marchepied vers la
présidentielle et sa très franchement du
point de vue des citoyennes des citoyens
des hôtes france je pense qu'il voit
bien là que le candidat à la régionale
xavier bertrand sera a priori très peu
de temps soucieux de la région une fois
élu s'il l'était donc il aurait plutôt
intérêt à faire en sorte que nous le
soyons d'autant plus que dans les autres
france tout de même depuis 2015 c'est de
la région est prise en étau dans un face
à face entre l'extrême droite et la
droite de monsieur bertrand
il est temps de respirer un peu on a
pris beaucoup de retard vous avez
bertrand il fait beaucoup de de
communication on a vu beaucoup s'agiter
avec des dispositifs comme proches
emploi et c'est bon ça sert un peu le
personnage le côté bonhomme mais en
rêviez derrière c'est très peu efficaces
et on a pris un retard considérable
notamment dans la bifurcation écologique
savait que xavier bertrand et d'ailleurs
c'est notoire dans son interview il n'y
a pas un mot de ce qu'il ferait face à
la crise climatique
or c'est quand même l'enjeu essentiel du
siècle mais vous n'allez pas faire
campagne différemment
ça changera rien xavier bertrand par
ailleurs fait le choix de s'affranchir
des primaires est ce que vous avez je
dirais un avis sur 7 sur cette attitude
écoutez moi la seule primaire véritable
que je le connaisse alors le fait qu'il
s'en émancipe à droite ça regarde la
droite
la seule véritable primaire que l'on
connaisse c'est le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle en réalité
vous allez bertrand se prépare la seule
chose qui soit sûre a priori il y aura
un premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle voilà j'ai pas de
commentaires je pourrais difficilement
dire autre chose alors que nous avons
fait de même à plusieurs fois avec jean
luc mélenchon
d'ailleurs et c'est le plus important ce
qui nous écoutent puisqu'il est question
présidentielle je les invite à se rendre
sur le site nous sommes pour point fr
parce que la candidature de rupture pour
2022 celle qui sera utile véritablement
séance d'aujourd'hui mais bon on va en
parler on va être juste finir alors oui
sur une sur une échéance lui plus proche
effectivement que la présidentielle dit
président de région vous l'avez lu exige
la tenue des élections en juin et pas
après est ce que vous partagez cette
position cotée depuis le début et y
compris quand monsieur debré nous a
consultés sur le sujet quand le
gouvernement l'a mandaté pour le faire
nous avons tenu la position suivante
avec la france en soumises moi je ne
suis pas bien placé j'ai pas les
indicateurs sanitaires qui me permettent
de dire quelle est la bonne date du
point de vue du calendrier pour ces
élections
en revanche nous disons une chose c'est
que une campagne électorale c'est pas
simplement le jour du scrutin les
opérations de vote ça veut dire
nécessairement que les semaines qui
précèdent ces opérations de vote doivent
être des semaines dans lesquelles il ya
de la contradiction politique il ya une
campagne populaire pour nous ç'a
toujours été simple soit les conditions
sont réunies
dad opérations de vote sur du point de
vue sanitaire et d'une campagne
populaire en amont et dans ce cas là on
peut voter soit ça n'est pas possible
dans ce cas là on doit reporter donc
c'est au gouvernement de le dire par
contre je vois que il n'a pas l'air de
s'agiter véritablement comme nous
l'avions demandée sur des méthodes pour
faire campagne en période de virus
decaux vide
on avait demandé que par exemple les
chaînes de télé et de radio soit
largement mises à contribution pour qui
est du débat
pour l'instant on va pas que ça bouge le
gouvernement n'a pas l'air non plus de
d'être très enjoué à l'idée de faire des
grandes campagnes pour l'inscription sur
les listes électorales
je sais pas combien de français sont au
courant
dans ce pays qui a une élection
logiquement au mois de juin je crois que
ça représente très peu de monde est
normalement le rôle de l'état c'est de
créer les conditions de faire savoir
qu'il ya un scrutin et d'organiser le
fait que les gens y participent on n'a
pas l'impression que ce soit la priorité
est alors justement ce que l'on sait
c'est aussi que de ce n'est pas une mais
deux deux élections qui sont censés donc
se tenir à savoir les départementales et
régionales
est-ce qu'il faut graver dans le marbre
ce principe ou puisque la france inscrit
émancipe pardon 2d des deux élections
fait dans la simultanéité ou est-ce
qu'il faut éventuellement pourquoi pas
fractionner en quelques c'est l'intérêt
parce qu'une élection double en quelque
sorte c'est peut-être aussi plus de plus
de risques plus de contraintes d'en
écouter je pense que maintenant les
choses ont été annoncées comme telles et
je crois y compris peut-être que du
point de vue sanitaire à la rigueur si
on fait les deux le même jour c'est
peut-être mieux que d'avoir deux
campagnes distinctes deux opérations de
vote faut peut-être aussi qu'on limite
et donc de ce point de vue c'est c'est
une bonne chose
alors justement dans cette élection on
le sait la france insoumise europe
ecologie les verts présentent
aujourd'hui leur union par amp ans entre
val de loire je crois que c'est cet
après midi alors vous n'oublierez
peut-être mais c'est pas non plus la a
priori que la france insoumise aura la
tête de liste est-ce que vous en
discutez encore où et j'irai est ce que
vous y croyez encore on s'est adressé
hier à europe ecologie les verts suite à
la proposition qui leur a été formulée
par jean luc mélenchon que j'ai
renouvelé qui consiste à dire écoutez on
est arrivé dans les hautes france on va
pouvoir y arriver dans d'autres régions
et nous nous y sommes prêts y compris à
céder la tête de liste à une tête de
liste europe écologie les verts dans
plusieurs régions à la condition que
juste à un endroit au moins il y ait une
réciproque par exemple en ile de france
où il ya une dynamique autour de la
campagne de clémentine autain on
pourrait imaginer que julien bayou té le
secrétaire nationale des verts face le
geste qui consiste à l'appuyer
ce pourrait être en paca ou ailleurs il
ya d'autres possibilités
en tout cas ce qui apparaît dans le
tableau général
des élections régionales c'est que
depuis le mois de juillet avec la france
en sont mises nous discutons avec nos
partenaires potentiels en leur disant il
faut créer les conditions d'être lisible
et donc nous cherchons un accord
national sur des bases claires des
programmes très clair finalement cette
stratégie n'a pas fonctionné parce que
partout où il ya de la géométrie
variable les verts c'est toujours
derrière eux c'est leur condition le
parti communiste qui est plutôt notre
notre allié naturel depuis plusieurs
élections fait le choix de plutôt
privilégier les alliances avec le parti
socialiste
donc au total nous essayons de les
fédérer région où il est derrière
notamment l'île de france alors que dans
la plupart des cas en tout cas à chaque
fois que le parti socialiste est sortant
le parti communiste français mais le
choix d'aller soutenir
nous ce que nous avons donc fait c'est
que partout région par région ce qu'on a
pas eu le choix en fait compte tenu du
fait que les partenaires fonctionne de
cette manière nous essayons de fédérer
sur des bases claires et le tableau
général qui sera lisible dès que les
discussions seront terminées c'est que
la france en sont mises dans ce scrutin
est le plus grand dénominateur commun à
gauche en quelque sorte capables de
s'entendre avec d'autres toujours sur
des bases claires pour faire des
campagnes
d'ailleurs dans leur vision générale
c'est pas plutôt que la france insoumise
n'arrive pas à faire l'union derrière
son nom non je crois au contraire
regardez par exemple vous avez cité les
autres france les autres ans vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir que la le rassemblement
qui a lieu a été rendue possible par la
france soumise
parce que c'était pas du tout ce qu
était prêt mais la france insoumise mais
écoutez il ya d'autres endroits par
exemple en ile de france ou clémentine
autain et tête de liste est soutenu par
le parti communiste
il ya d'autres endroits notamment en
région rhône alpes auvergne nous
soutenons nous une tête de liste
communiste d'ailleurs l'alliance entre
la france en sont mises et le parti
communiste la bassée fait contre l'avis
de la direction communiste bon vous
voyez tout ça est compliqué en revanche
légèrement un dernier mot là dessus
parce qu'après on va parler de la crise
sanitaire mais
vous parlez de la candidature de
jean-luc mélenchon à la présidentielle
et ce qui ne va pas avoir besoin des
parrainages des élus communistes pour
être candidat et est ce qu'on ne vous
avions pas avec fabien roussel en tout
cas mais on pas me fabien roussel en
tête de liste dans les hauts de france
vous n'êtes pas en train de compromettre
sa candidature à la présidentielle non
pourquoi ce que nous avons fait dans les
autres france c'est permettre ce qu'il
se passe aujourd'hui c'est à dire le
fait qu' un rassemblement très large
sans quoi sans doute même le parti
communiste et les verts n'auraient pas
été sur la même liste et ça c'est nous
qui l'avons rendu possible et je crois
que c'est une bonne chose compte tenu de
ce que j'expliquais tout à l'heure le
fait qu' il n'y a pas un élu de gauche
dans cet hémicycle régional depuis 2015
après écoute et les communistes ont une
décision à prendre
au mois de mai prochain moi ce que
j'observe c'est que à deux reprises dans
les deux dernières élections
présidentielles nous avons su nous
regrouper autour du même candidat et du
même programme
non sans un certain succès tout le monde
l'a vu et je crois que la troisième
peut-être la bonne est qu'on peut faire
mieux et 2022 vraiment qu'il vous
accorderont leur parrainage alors que
fabien roussel dit qu'il va écouter un
bon les parrainages vous parlez des 500
signatures d'élus écouter la dernière
fois pour tout vous dire on y arriver
sans une grande aide du parti communiste
des maires communistes n'ont pas attendu
les consignes du parti pour parrainer
jean luc mélenchon mais finalement on
était quasiment au bout quand ils ont
décidé de dégeler les signatures donc
c'est pas le plus grand des problèmes
maintenant je le dis le ce qui serait
préférable c'est que nous ayons une
alliance avec le parti communiste
français qui lie les présidentielles la
question du programme et franchement
c'est pas compliqué 90 % de nos votes
sont communs à l'assemblée et à deux
reprises nous avons été à la
présidentielle avec le même programme et
qu'on est avant la présidentielle
un bel accord au législatif qui
permettra à chacun de s'y retrouver
on va parler de la crise sanitaire
manager sur cette crise donc on le sait
plusieurs départements sont en sursis si
l'on peut dire est ce que la stratégie
territorialisées
je dirai toujours la bonne femme aux
yeux coûté ce que je vois surtout c'est
que maintenant ça fait un an que la
situation sanitaire dur et que le
gouvernement pendant une année a tout
raté
voilà au début on faisait attention
tirez pas sur l'ambulance on faisait des
propositions on était prudent se disait
où là il ya un virus les décisions sont
difficiles à prendre mais que voit-on
maintenant évidemment que la question
prioritaire désormais c'est celle du
vaccin
or la stratégie vaccinale notamment
grâce à l'union européenne qui protège
elle patine complètement
regardez le week-end dernier par exemple
en france nous avons fait quelque chose
comme 200 6000 vaccination dans le même
temps la grande bretagne en faisait plus
d'un million donc il ya véritablement un
problème du point de vue de l'union
européenne la manière dont les choses
ont été organisées avec les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
donc les jeunes français alors on donne
une chose qui est une duplicité du
gouvernement et des manuels macron dans
cette affaire vous avez le ms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
dit la pandémie et mondiale le vaccin
doit être un bien commun de l'humanité
émancipée des logiques commerciales
monsieur macron dit oui d'accord
d'ailleurs il le répète souvent la
télévision le vaccin bien commun la
réalité c'est que la france il ya quinze
jours de ça la france à l'organisation
mondiale du commerce avec l'union
européenne toute entière s'est opposé à
la levée des brevets sur les vaccins or
on le voit bien aujourd'hui je le redis
sur votre plateau la levée des brevets
est une absolue priorité pourquoi parce
qu'il ya des vaccins qui sont produits
et qui sont conçus un peu partout mais
qu'on ne peut pas produire parce que
cette propriété intellectuelle alors
bien sûr il ya la question des capacités
de production mais si les brevets est
élevée on pourrait produire partout des
vaccins venus de partout et d'ailleurs
je le redis aussi pas d'idéologie avec
le vaccin
quand j'entends monsieur thierry breton
dire qu'il ne veut pas du vaccin russe
je m'interroge pourquoi parce qu'ils les
russes c'est ça le problème
moi je le dis très clairement critique
nous le disent on a besoin du vaccin
russe pour atteindre le nombre d'écoutés
que les choses soient claires vu la
situation sanitaire vue le fait que la
vaccination est largement prioritaire
pour faire face à l'épidémie
j'ai résumé les choses en peu de mots
d'où qu'ils viennent quel que soit le
régime politique depuis lequel il
provient si le vaccin est sûr et
efficace il doit être proposé et nous
avons donc besoin que la france mette en
bonne corrélation les jolis mots du
président de la république avec ses
actes en participant à l'opération de
levée
brevet pour produire mais retombe dit
que de toute façon l'europe sera le
premier continent à produire les vaccins
il parle de 2 milliards de doses qui
seront produites et que du coup en gros
y'a pas besoin d'élever des brevets pour
pour produire des vaccins a coûté on
attend toujours de le voir mais si nous
avions levé les brevets d'ores et déjà
il ya des unités de production par
exemple de sanofi sanofi qui nous avait
promis un vaccin qui ont visiblement on
n'aura pas d'accent sanofi en tout cas
pas tout de suite qui à distribuer 4
milliards de dividendes à ses
actionnaires et qui dans le même temps
ferme des centres de recherche notamment
400 suppressions de postes dans la
recherche on a passé de 11 centres à 3
bon tout ça est un véritable fiasco
si nous avions la levée des brevets on
pourrait produire notamment dans les
usines sanofi du vaccin venus d'ailleurs
par exemple n'en déplaise à monsieur
breton le vaccin russe il ya des sites
de production en afrique du sud aussi il
ya des choses à faire
ensuite sur la stratégie confinement
déconfinement ce que l'on voit bien
c'est que sa stratégie a atteint ses
limites d'ailleurs on y comprend
vraiment plus rien les dernières
annonces de monsieur castex alors un
confinement des confiné dehors un
couvre-feu qui repoussait à plus tard
les attestations c'est les deux les
justificatifs de domicile bref tout ça
est absolument incompréhensible et
atteint finalement la discipline
sanitaires ça fait depuis le mois de
novembre qu'avec jean luc mélenchon nous
disons au gouvernement vous n'allez pas
pouvoir gérer cette crise plus
durablement avec les faits confinement
déconfinement et nous proposons des
alternatives au confinement de quoi
s'agit-il
quand monsieur macron fait son pari de
ne par confiner c'est peut-être bien
pensé mais il s'agit pas juste de dire
je ne confirme pas il faut organiser les
conditions que sans le confiner la
circulation du virus ne s'emballe pas
sinon après on se retrouve dans la
situation que nous avons aujourd'hui
sous les yeux c'est à dire l'obligation
de reconfirmer les alternatives au
confinement c'est le renforcement
drastique des protocoles sanitaires
l'équipement partout de purificateurs
d'air avoir des protocoles extrêmement
précis et organiser la société par
roulement c'est-à-dire on peut tout
réouvrir on peut enfin revivre
véritablement c'est pas métro boulot
dodo
mais avec des protocoles sanitaires et
l'organisation de roulement pour que la
vie reprenne sans que l'épidémie
circulent plus avant sinon on
être condamné durablement à ces
stratégies on ouvre on ferme on ouvre on
ferme mais je crois que les français en
sont arrivés à saturation
j'imagine que vous avez lu ce que dit
olivier ferrand de la france insoumise
qui lui reprochent de n'avoir rien prévu
rien organisé il a dit dimanche dans le
parisien les français n'ont pas besoin
du venant de jean luc mélenchon si le
copéisme pouvait sauver des vies ça se
saurait tout d'abord les révoltés ils
ont besoin des accents de monsieur vers
ans qui pour l'instant tarder à arriver
moi ce que je vois surtout c'est que
depuis le début de la crise et olivier
ferrand le sait même si le fait de la
politique depuis le début de la crise
nous avons posé des kilos de proposition
sur la table qui ont tous toutes été
balayée d'un revers de la main pendant
la première vague
on leur a proposé un plan complet de
déconfinement pour dire vous confie
n'est d'accord mais donc préparons
l'après ayons attendent avance quand
vous avez desserrer l'étau il va falloir
l'organiser on savait dire vous êtes des
tireurs dans le dos on confine vous
parlez de déconfinement mais c'est pas
pour contester votre décision c'est pour
dire il faut se préparer donc
aujourd'hui je le redis peut-être que
compte tenu du fait qu'ils n'ont rien
préparé ils n'ont pas d'autre choix
aujourd'hui que de procéder à des
confidences complètement incohérent
comme ce qu'on a sous les yeux par
ailleurs mais par pitié maintenant
préparons la suite et faisons en sorte
qu'en plus du vaccin
en plus de la question du traitement on
prépare des alternatives si l'épidémie
dur pour ne pas être obligé d'avoir pour
seule méthode l'enferment justement
dernier mot sur la suite avant de parler
de la dette avec eric il y avait un
débat à l'assemblée nationale sur cette
question de la crise sanitaire et
olivier ferrand il a dit espérer pouvoir
rouvrir les lieux accueillant du public
sans avoir recourt pas sanitaire est ce
que vous êtes favorable à ce passé long
terme
non d'abord je crois que pour qui un
pass sanitaires il faut qu'ils aient des
vaccins et que les gens qui souhaitent
se faire vacciner puisse le faire or ce
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
et puis le pass sanitaire finalement
c'est une forme d'injonction
d'obligations à la vaccination
et j'observe que même les organismes les
plus sérieux sur la santé disent qu'il
vaut mieux créer l'adhésion et susciter
l'adhésion que de contraindre est obligé
mais évidemment qu'avec des protocoles
sanitaires on peut ré ouvrir moi je
pense ce matin à tous ces lieux de
culture plus de 70 théâtre qui sont
occupées pour dire non seulement à bâle
assurances la réforme de l'assurance
chômage
plus fin le renouvellement de l'année
blanche mais qui surtout disent aussi il
faut maintenant réouvrir et très
franchement quand on voit ce qu'on peut
faire dans les magasins quand on voit
les files d'attentes aux caisses on
comprend mal qu'on ne puisse pas aller
dans des lieux où par ailleurs vous le
savez les protocoles sanitaires sont
tout à fait
disponible on peut les mettre en place
quand je vois par exemple des émissions
de télé comme j'en ai vu récemment sur
le service public avec des humoristes où
il ya du public
alors certes masqué avec de la distance
mais les gens assistent à quoi sinon un
spectacle c'est bien que c'est possible
de l'organiser qui on en a besoin en
bout d'un moment sinon la quatrième
vague comme jean luc mélenchon l'a dit
ça va être une vague psychologique parce
qu'on connaît aussi les effets du
confinement sur le moral des gens que
nous ne sommes pas simplement des homo
economicus qui allons au boulot fille
qui rentre on pour renouveler notre
force de travail on a besoin de se
divertir de se cultiver de se rencontrer
donc il faut l'organiser il s'agit pas
de nier la gravité de la situation
sanitaire
mais organiser la vie avec cette
situation on va parler de la dette
puisqu'il y avait là aussi un débat à
l'assemblée cette semaine
oui c'est un débat donc qui a eu lieu
lundi alors jean-luc mélenchon s'est
exprimé il a notamment indiqué que
rembourser la dette c'était un sujet
pour imposer des politiques d'austérité
dont acte mais est-ce que c'est pas un
peu caricatural de poser les choses à
non pas du tout d'abord vous dire une
chose c'est que c'est très clair la
dette est le meilleur allié de ceux qui
prônent la baisse des dépenses publiques
elle leur permet de justifier leur
préférence pour la baisse des dépenses
publiques bon regardons d'abord souvent
dans le débat public on compare la dette
publique aux adeptes d'un ménage ça n'a
rien de comparable
et heureusement d'ailleurs que la dette
d'un ménage n'est pas amené à une année
de sa production comme l'est la dette
qui est assise sur la question du
produit intérieur brut
non aujourd'hui faut regarder la
composition la dette publique que nous
avons nous estimons que 25% de cette
dette et notamment le fait des baisses
d'impôts successives des cadeaux faits
aux plus riches des baisses d'impôts de
production d'ailleurs souvent inutile
donc on peut interroger d'abord sa
composition mais surtout dire une chose
c'est clair que compte tenu de son
volume
si les taux augmentent parce
qu'aujourd'hui les taux sont bas et le
fait que les taux sont bas fait que
alors qu on est cinq fois plus endettés
que dans les années 80 on dépense moins
et la france dépense moins pour honorer
en quelque sorte le paiement des
intérêts si les taux en revanche avait à
augmenter là il y aurait un problème et
il faut dire une chose dire on va
rembourser la dette à tout prix ça veut
dire dire aux générations futures
vous ne ferez pas les investissements
nécessaires pour la bifurcation
écologique et vous vous ségneré au
travail juste pour rembourser la dette
ça ce n'est pas possible nous avons
besoin
d'investir beaucoup pour faire la
bifurcation écologique pour faire tout
ce qu'il ya lieu de faire
alors il y à des méthodes qui certes ne
conviennent pas aux partisans du
remboursement de la dette pour justifier
la baisse des dépenses publiques mais il
ya des méthodes tranquille pacifique qui
sont pas du tout ridicule qui permettent
de régler le problème tranquillement et
d'ailleurs le gouvernement le sait bien
la fed la banque centrale des états unis
vient de racheter pour 2300 milliards de
titres de dette donc nous ce que nous
disons quand on parle d' annulation
c'est un terme un peu rapide pour dire
les choses mais en fait c'est que la
banque centrale européenne continue de
racheter directement aux états des
titres de dettes et les classes dans ce
qu'on appelle la dette perpétuelle
souvenez-vous que en 1953 il a été
décidé d'un trait de plume d'éponger 50%
de la dette de l'allemagne et à ce
moment là on n'a pas dit qu'on était
furieux de le faire donc voilà il faut
dire les choses
annuler la dette classer les titres de
dettes en dettes perpétuelles c'est une
solution sérieuse pour donner de la
respiration
adrien catelet s'il ne reste
malheureusement peu tant question
d'actualité évidemment et cette
polémique qui continuent autour des
réunions organisées par l'unef le
syndicat étudiant qui organise des
réunions non mixtes racisées
frédéric vidal la ministre elle a réagi
hier c'était lors des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement au sénat l'a
dit que ces réunions trahi ssait les
valeurs fondamentales de notre
république n'a t'elle pas raison non
c'est d'un ridicule absolu ce qui est
grave à 7h d'abord c'est le fait que
soient réclamés
y compris d'ailleurs dans cette période
où la jeunesse payant très lourd tribut
de la crise sanitaire
la dissolution d'un syndicat étudiant
que des gens osent réclamer la
dissolution c'est franchement un
franchissement de seuil qui est très
grave
de quoi s'agit-il et même moi d'ailleurs
vous savez depuis quelques années j'ai
appris de quoi il s'agissait et j'ai
fait évoluer ma position il s'agit de
groupes de parole non pas des réunions
où les décisions se prennent dans le
syndicat c'est des groupes de paroles
qui permettent à des gens qui vivent des
discriminations par exemple des femmes
qui sont victimes de violences sexistes
et sexuelles de discuter de ce qu'elles
subissent entre elles ça veut pas dire
que c'est excluant par principe et qu on
se coupe du reste de la population c'est
pas le sujet de la même manière vous
avez des personnes qui vivent toutes
sortes de discriminations le racisme et
convient de se retrouver pour en parler
mais ya finalement une manipulation
quand on parle d'une réunion qui
regroupe des gens qui parlent entre eux
de leur discrimination et de dire
ensuite et de commenter en disant ces
réunions sont interdites aux blancs est
ce que par exemple quand madame pécresse
fait une réunion des femmes
d'ile-de-france ont dit aulas à madame
pécresse a fait une réunion interdite
aux hommes non elle a fait une réunion
vaut ces réunions il y avait des femmes
qu'un problème ces réunions en tout cas
ne mérite pas du tout la dissolution la
demande de dissolution d'un syndicat et
surtout c'est vieux comme le comme le
monde les groupes de paroles ça existe
depuis très longtemps donc ça vous gêne
pas pour moi c'est une véritable
manipulation que ce qui est demandé la
et franchement vous regardez un peu ce
qui se passe
il ya plein de groupes ou la non mixité
existe et où ça pose pas problème
quand vous avez ces clubs de grands
bourgeois d'automobiles qui sont
réservées aux hommes ont dit pas c'est
interdit aux femmes vous voyez un peu le
franchissement de seuil qu'il ya et je
redis car ils syndication mais le de
couleur de peau le syndicat unef
n'organise pas ses prises de décisions
et ses instances
en fonction de la couleur de peau dire
ça c'est absolument ridicule donc donc
voila moi je m'offusque de ces
franchissements de seuil et qu'on
réclame la dissolution d'un syndicat
étudiant d'un syndicat de jeunesse y
compris dans cette période spécialement
difficile pour les jeunes
sur cette base et corrigé
du vin je dérive incroyable de l'unef
sur le sujet du racisme vous n'êtes pas
d'accord mais je pense véritablement que
la dérive à l'est aussi au parti
socialiste où il ya là dedans des gens
qui avaient comme d'ailleurs pendant des
années militer dans ce syndicat et qui
aujourd'hui sont incapables de le
défendre
je crois que quand il ya des
franchissements de seuil même si parfois
ça coûte
il faut tenir bon et savoir rappeler des
positions et dernière question
rapidement alors sur le droit à l'eau et
le droit à l'accès on sait que c'est un
enjeu crucial
selon vous comment tu es ce que vous
aller sensibiliser l'opinion à écouter
on essaye de mener cette campagne qui
est emmenée par ma collègue matt hill
panneaux la france insoumise avec des
partenaires on a ouvert sa le 22 mars
jusqu'au 13 avril
j'invite celles et ceux qui nous
écoutent à aller sur le site internet au
point vote
la question qui est posée c'est elle
vous favorable à l'inscription dans la
constitution du droit à l'eau à son
assainissement et au fait que l'eau ne
soit pas accaparé par les
multinationales on le sait notamment les
français payent 10 à 25% plus cher leur
facture d'eau lorsque c'est le privé qui
s'en occupe
et puis surtout la question de l'eau va
être fondamental car l'eau se raréfie
les nations unies nous disent que d'ici
à 2034 milliard de personnes vont vivre
dans des zones qui vont manquer d'eau et
en france déjà deux millions de
personnes ont du mal à payer leurs
factures donc l'eau est un enjeu central
donc direction le site internet au vote
et le message est passé merci beaucoup
bien sûr mais un 4 mars d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin merci eric richard
la une de la nouvelle république ce sont
ces classes fermées à cause du coc vide
c'est-à-dire ce matin dans votre journal
merci bien sûr si on passe ensuite au
club des territoires la mutuelle
nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux
présente le club des territoires angie
acteurs engagés n'aurait transition zéro
carbone des régions vous présente le
club des territoires
[Musique]